well I think every entrepreneur who goes
out and dedicates their life and throws
everything behind a venture has some
moment where they thought this is the
thing that I have to do and for me with
crowdfunder after having done several
ventures I actually experienced a bit of
anxiety about what am I going to do next
and so in some ways there was this
moment of or several moments of a fear
of failure or what I'm gonna do this
time but it was about four years ago
that after a long series of a couple of
successful startups a couple of failed
ones I saw this opportunity with a very
small group of people who wanted to
change how some of the investment laws
in the United States really worked and
they were really about changing those to
help small business owners and
entrepreneurs specifically giving them
more of an opportunity to go out and
raise money from say their local
community or the people around them
maybe not just friends and family but a
broader audience and it's actually funny
when you went look into the securities
laws that govern how you can fundraise
for a private company in the u.s. that
it turns out you're not supposed to talk
to anyone that you don't already know so
in a lot of ways for an entrepreneur
who's starting a business for their
first time even if they're bright even
if they have domain expertise if they're
technically skilled but they haven't
started a business and they don't know a
bunch of wealthy investors they're at a
pretty significant disadvantage so being
someone who's really grown up around the
web who started my first company in the
web 1.0 boom and really have fallen in
love with the idea that technology can
connect us to like-minded communities
and help us in a variety of ways in our
lives
I felt really passionate about the idea
of hey couldn't finance change in this
way couldn't finance be more
collaborative and help serve
entrepreneurs and it spoke to me really
significantly that there could be an
opportunity to change how investing laws
work because I had been that
entrepreneur in my past I had had a
couple of adventures that have been
successful started in investing in and
funding some of my own ideas and also
failed it
those and actually failed specifically
raising money for a company that I had
put really about a quarter million of my
own money in and that was right around
2008 in a very difficult market to raise
venture and kind of what's left sitting
on my hands and saying man I wish there
was a better solution
so crowdfunder for me is a lot of ways a
combination and a culmination of a
variety of different passions in my life
it's about entrepreneurship but it's
also about investing and I think as
entrepreneurs evolve and they have
successes and failures they feel
compelled and drawn to the idea of I
want to help some other entrepreneurs so
really crowdfund for me is not only
putting this disruptive idea of
exponential Tuchman technology squarely
on early-stage finance and disrupting
that market but it's also about helping
entrepreneurs at scale and that's
something that I'm really passionate
about I do believe that there are parts
of the market that are being disrupted
through equity crowdfunding but that's
not really my viewpoint I'm probably
more of a collaborator than I am a
jabber meaning I don't think that
crowdfunding and equity crowdfunding
should disrupt and replace VCS and I
don't think we should do away with
angels or angel groups however I am a
strong believer that over the long term
distributed technologies automation can
really scale beyond the the limits of
what humans can do and start to do a lot
of the more mundane or analytic jobs a
lot better and then it can also help
communicate at scale but it still takes
human beings with the relationships with
many many years of experience to really
add value on top of that and make
meaning out of all of that so I see that
we're complementing and disrupting
venture capital at the same time our
business today works best when we work
alongside create venture investors
whether that's at the seed stage or its
later stage and we get involved and help
raise money for companies that are
proving and have some validation and we
really further validate them but I do
think as this market evolves it's really
year one for equity crowdfunding and
we've done nearly a quarter billion
dollars in financing the first year
that's going to
chilli grow what happens then when you
can invest alongside these much bigger
institutional funds that's a huge
opportunity and it wasn't available even
several years ago and it's going to be
widely available to the eight and a half
million accredited investors in the US
so I feel like we are disrupting it but
it's best in my mind when you
collaborate with the thought leaders
when you collaborate with the smartest
people and the most wisdom and
experience in this area I also see that
crowdfunder is disrupting early-stage
finance as a whole by looking to create
an entirely new capital market so in a
variety of internet and technology
driven businesses you see that there's a
couple of winners in this given niche
but crowdfunding is different and
Finance is different because it's really
about creating a giant capital market so
if I was to say to you at the dawn of
capital markets in the public markets in
the US like the New York Stock Exchange
that there would be one investment bank
that would help raise money and do all
the banking for public country meetings
on Wall Street you would look at me and
say this person doesn't understand what
a capital market is they're crazy what
we're seeing is the dawn and the birth
of a brand new capital market that is in
itself a disruption and a creation of a
new capital market for entrepreneurship
and for venture and there's going to be
a variety of players crowdfunder
included in them that can help serve a
really important function and role in
this market so not only seeing the 30
billion dollar venture investor annual
market being disrupted and brought
online through equity crowdfunding we're
seeing the 20 to 25 billion dollar angel
investment market being brought online
and partially disrupted but we're seeing
a brand new capital market about to be
born
and that's everyday people that can
invest in these companies alongside
those other more experienced investors
and that's going to change the the face
of fundraising for equity and it's going
to change the game for how entrepreneurs
speak to the people that can support
them
naturally